let's go to let's go to our friend
Manuel Antonio Rodriguez calling I
believe from Mexico City or at least
potentially from Mexico City
of course I'm actually calling you live
I not from Beverly Hills our
organization the mobile workers alliance
actually having a a protest outside of
the uber uber founder Garrett camps on
house but anyways my question is is this
the last time we spoke we're speaking
about uber and lyft drivers and I want
to talk to you about that again but I
want to tell you about some developments
so the California governor Gavin Newsom
signed a new law recently were basically
in California
uber and lyft drivers another like you
know who delivery people are going to be
considered employees now and no longer
independent contractors right back
flowers and a kick in January 1 and
basically it's going to have more
protection for us for us drivers and you
know we're gonna hopefully we'll be you
know able to collect you know wages you
know overtime wages once we start doing
their I will have more you know most
benefit hopefully some paid sick leave
with that but here's the kicker
uber and lyft and door - recently
announced that they're gonna put 90
million dollars towards basically
reversing that through one of those a
throw California state initiative you
know it procs yes and that's set to take
basically they're gonna try to put it on
the November 2020 ballot I guess I want
to hear what you think about that I mean
it is direct democracy in a sense that
people get to vote on these laws but you
know the way we see it is that and
they're calling to protect California
app drivers something like that and so
basically there's a point in this law
and they're trying to say that they're
gonna do they're gonna provide a lot of
benefits such as minimum wage but when
you actually look at the details you
know some of these things they don't
need to do it through us through a
California state initiative they could
if they want to pay us more or if they
want to pay as a minimum they could
start doing it tomorrow but that makes
sense I want you
like absolutely this this is gonna be a
massive propaganda campaign this will be
a massive propaganda campaign they're
gonna pour money in they've calculated
that getting this reversed is worth more
than the 90 million they're gonna put in
I don't know if that's the number you're
saying it's the number I believe you but
it may not be let's assume that it is
and you're absolutely right they're
going to package it as if if we reverse
the decision about the uber and lyft
drivers having to be classified as
employees we will raise wages and we
will do all these different things and
you're completely right they could have
done all of those things all along and
it is direct democracy but when one side
has 90 million is it really a fair
playing field as the question and this
is what I wear that comes up in these
cases so listen I think it's the right
decision for the drivers to be
classified as employees I would not be
surprised if there is a very effective
campaign mounted to get it overturned
but I do think that it is not clear that
they can win that on a ballot initiative
I think that that a lot of people
everywhere including in California
understand the importance of why the
drivers should be classified as
employees so we'll see how it develops
right and let me just tell you one of
the things that they're proposing and
they enlisted of so supposedly they're
going to the same as minimum wage now
which is all great and like I said they
can start doing that tomorrow if they
really wanted to pay you some new ways
right but the way they want to calculate
minimum wage is not if as soon as we
accept the rider so a lot of times
rather than sitting in their cars
waiting to pick up people but it's not
busy or the area that they're in is not
you know no one's requesting any right
so they're already having loopholes in
that so they're nice right for waiting
so in an hour if in an if in a real hour
you had 40 minutes during which you were
on rides
you really are only owed 2/3 of an hour
of minimum wage even though you were in
the car for the run 60 minutes yeah yeah
so we have hundreds of drivers here in
Beverly Hills and we're gonna go you
know to the mansion you just bought it
he paid seventy two point five million
dollars for this mansion one of the
biggest purchases here in the in Beverly
Hills in the 902 one oh well we drivers
were sick of it David and so you know if
there's any drivers listening I hope
they can get involved with them I work
right okay Manuel Antonio always a
pleasure great to hear from you okay you
all min there all right we will talk to
you soon let's take a quick break don't
hang up if you were on the phone because
we will go right back to the phones on
the other side of this break